you're a very good interview I've
watched you for years and you're
wonderful and I'm not going down that
road I am sticking with what I'm asking
for please our governor I'm focused on
what you're saying that's your opinion
of what you think I'm saying and I am
being very clear Anderson Cooper
straight up grills Las Vegas mayor
Carolyn Goodman on Wednesday night and
their battle has everyone talking and
when he said this germ wait one second
you asked the question let me interrupt
you I'm okay thank you
but maybe it's breathing I'm sorry being
silly here mayor Goodman joined Anderson
Cooper 360 via video chat and talked
about her recent call to reopen Las
Vegas despite the ongoing coronavirus
crisis doesn't that sound like a virus
petri dish I mean how would that know
what it sounds like you're being an
alarmist
I'm not she's been pretty vocal about
her opposition to the stay at home order
issued by the Nevada governor and
Anderson well he took her to task asking
her all the tough questions I'm sorry
you're the mayor of Las Vegas yeah you
want casinos to be open even though you
have no authority over casinos but yes
you say open them up but you have no
responsibilities about how that would be
done said it's not your job there yeah
there was a lot of that no no no no no
no going on testing you're putting words
in my mouth I said open up Las Vegas
absolutely I'm out you just say excuse
me I want to just show you know they're
talking disease I'm talking life I'm
talking life and living these are people
who are attached to us honestly this
whole thing just calls for an epic
montage of all the wild faces Anderson
made
[Music]
but this one this is my personal fave
yeah Anderson was pretty peeved and it
only got worse Chinese researchers have
shown how this virus spreads I just want
to put up yours I just want to put up
our viewers this is a resting you are
trying to this isn't China Vegas Nevada
Wow okay that's really ignorant this is
a restaurant and the yellow statement
that's that's a restaurant and yes it's
in China but there are human beings too
well fans of Anderson including Jimmy
Kimmel a Las Vegas native took to
Twitter to give the journalists mad
props for grilling the mayor like he did
Jimmy tweeted quote dear Las Vegas it
would appear that your mayor of Las
Vegas Carolyn Goodman is dangerously
misguided I am not easily shocked
anymore but the interview she is doing
with Anderson Cooper CNN right now is
bonkers another fan tweeted this moment
from the sit-down writing yeah me too
Anderson Cooper well another person
called the whole interview a spectacular
trainwreck then there's my personal fave
this tweet pointing out how Anderson's
blink rate increases with the amount of
dumb he is confronted with it's like
using Morse code to say what the actual
if you if casinos reopen are you gonna
be inside those casinos every single
night putting your own life on the line
I have lived in this town for 56 years
are you gonna go to casinos every night
and put your life on the line like all
the workers you say you're there they
don't need it we weren't broken we s
tragically have a hundred and fifty
people we lost tragic
we have 2.3 million people here I
haven't heard you say yes that you would
be sitting on those casino floors every
night along with the people that you say
you are holding their hands with and
that is what we call a mic drop
what is the purpose of that first of all
I have the family because putting money
where your mouth is to use I guess that
Las Vegas USA safe okay so you're not
willing to sit on the casino floors
[Music]
that's the sound I feel like he's making